citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tera Ericson alongside my friend Batman
sorry what's your real name it's Bruce
Wayne oh that's a good name too but tell
them your real name okay Andrew Flash
Gordon a that's such a cool name we're
going to watch Now You See Me Do you see
me right now no where are you oh there
you are somewhere better than this I'll
tell you that much listen you got to
leave a like you got to type in the
computer you got to leave comments you
guys so that people think we are cool
and you also have to ring the
bell ring the
bell yeah you got to get on our side
ring that Bell also if you're not
already on patreon you need to get on
there because then you can sync up with
your full copy watch the whole thing
with me and Batman right here the whole
entire movie you know you you might miss
stuff if you're not on patreon you get
the whole thing like stuff that we're
saying like M and A's and I don't know
jokes that may maybe didn't make the cut
you know what I mean might miss some
references from me yes and he he has a
lot almost too many sometimes I'm might
close the book for a second you know
it's a lot he can fire a lot at you so
get prepped okay guys don't forget that
GRE and John covers several shows over
there on patreon exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included so just get to patreon you guys
know what's good for you are you ready
so ready okay want to see some magic
yeah Now You See Me Now you don't here
we
go come in close because the more you
think you see the easier it'll be to
fool
you did you see one yes now do you see
your card here no that's because you're
looking too
closely what is making it rain with
cards I guess
so oh that's cool oh that's awesome nice
that was amazing now look into my
eyes
and you can get this bill from me you
can have it get it if you can say your
name you can
have why can't anyone play this game
with me you're thinking of a woman's
name a b c d e f g h i j Jean Jane Janet
who's Janet uh what it's not your best
friend is
he your sister pleas Bo buddy you were
away on Janet your wife sister
okay what is this uh 200 seem fair you
know what this is a big deal let's go
250 you're a stickup artist
andle now when I snap my fingers you
won't remember any of this right in the
middle of everywhere too and think of
Janet you're going to picture me naked
and that's not a pretty s yeah and wide
awake he didn't even need a room for
that we did the best we could but some
people just wanten to be hypnotized I
did it wrong oh no you did it fine did
good I mean I'm 250 bucks uh cheap less
than my wallet but we did fine
$100 anyone who can tell me how this
trick is done I have an ordinary spoon
from Mel's Deli right here in Brooklyn
check it out there is no
spoon I'm about to bend this spoon with
my
mind how thank you thank you around this
what are you doing uh I got other trick
or you can give me my 100 bucks you have
a very good eye sir
thanks yeah but he didn't say you could
physically touch me he said to tell me
yeah
man get the rules right
bro
oh dang love it score he is a magician
after all that guy in the Le Jack he's
got my
wallet that's awesome I mean I'm not for
thievery but that was awesome I'm all
for
thievery zero a tank full of fles eating
piranhas will fall from above a lady has
to have handcuffs right girl oh I love
her who hey girl hey my God those guys
looked way too excited just to see a
girl in
like a bathing
[Applause]
[Music]
suit
ah oh she serious she can't get
up
get ever since the prestige I don't I
don't like these kinds of scenes what
the H feel like it's part of the act but
I can't tell yeah I can't tell
[Music]
either
what what what what what
what how you going to escape
that no oh that's going to be crazy to
escape that she's escaping I'm telling
you this is this is great this is a
great stunt yeah no she's for sure
escaping
whoever say us
oh that was
awesome oh my God
spooky oh
my so hard oh thank you is it always a
seven I can do that trick 52 different
ways can you do 52 different tricks on
me I'll see what I can
do who hold on
what 45 east7 no don't don't worry about
it I I'll call you you don't have my
number a magic I'll find it have a good
night it's like look for my number on
the side of a building h
yeah well we got our roster of group of
magicians ah somebody want to kill these
magicians what's this card stuff about
I'm assuming the card that they all have
is from that person in the hood oh yes
who's just been lurking around just
watching them inspecting them making
sure they're all worthy of of being
magicians I didn't know you had to be
worthy of that you're going to join the
club whosoever holds this Hammer if he
be worthy shall possess the power of
th oh all right can she reach in there
bring them all
together Danny her name's Henley you
wait out here I will come back and get
you okay do not come in hey Danny not
your assistant anymore nice
hair okay so apparently none of us was
the only one chosen let me be the first
one to kick my ego to the
curb you now hold it don't tell me uh
Helen no no Henley it's on your coffee
cup thanks for keeping me
honest sensing you are a control freak
well I take that as a compliment only he
would take it as a compliment good
another
compliment that's why you're no longer a
couple no no we never never a couple is
this
foreshadowing they're going to end up
married at the end of the movie I I see
it Daniel Atlas do I have seen
everything that you have ever done I
mean you're like I idolize you seriously
a true fan it's so nice to meet you we
we waiting for someone why why are we
just door locked oh no nothing nothing's
ever locked who's behind the door the
oracle
yeah what's going on
here perect guy to have that was so
fast what's it say it's a test now you
don't H aose By Any Other
[Music]
Name oh what
the oh it's going to fill up that little
thing on the
floor
who electricity is
out oh let's check feels like it's out
of a saw
movie yeah it kind of
does
blueprints okay this doesn't look like
magic it looks like engineering and
[Music]
math
huh roll
credits the end that was a good movie oh
so
good Meritt mckin oh Daniel
Atlas Henley
Reeves Jack Wilder The Four Horsemen oh
all right we're going to do something
never before seen on a Las Vegas stage
or any stage for that matter that's a
humongous crowd yeah and a giant
stage we are going to rubber Bank cool
that's funny I've seen that done once in
a Batman the Animated Series episode
with zatana really they did that yeah
something along the lines of that
yeah Morgan Freeman oh I didn't know he
was in this no recording allowed during
the performance oh yeah yeah sure cool
let me just put this away actually I
need to take that
okay oh dude the same kind of trick in
the Dark Knight and Jack B are ping pong
balls with Section number jack can you
hand me a section number thank you we
are looking at section B I want to go to
this show seriously it's not the same
show but this makes me sad I never got
to see sik freed and Roy oh yeah we are
looking at row number five where is that
and uh Henley can I please have a random
seat number lucky number 13 b513 is it
going to be Morgan Freeman or oh no ah
there you are hi my name Isen forier and
my bank
it's can you please come up to the stage
we'll uh Rob your
bank there is someone here tonight
without whom we would just be four
magicians working the circuit they Mr
Arthur Trester please stand up Arthur
the only man here with the queen cell
phone hey M
Kane I love him damn they got Alfred and
lucious Fox here my cocaine we haven't
done our closer yet why you watch it and
then you can decide for yourself oh he's
doing his hypnotic trick on him oh
interesting what Jack is bringing to the
stage now is what we in the Magic World
teleportation helmet crazy this is it
will allow you to literally to your bank
it has the added attraction of being
very stylish it's about time the French
learn from America on that
subject you can take that one okay there
you go now show to your friends in
section B there but but not to
us card we started the movie out
with put it in your pocket and now for
one tiny
detail but oh my God how'd she do that
get out of
here whoa all right cool that's 8:50
a.m. in Paris your bank opens in less
than 10 minutes 1 2
3 oh my God that's terrifying I like
that little French guy where'd he
go no
really oh my god there he
is how I want you to take the card that
you signed out of your pocket and I want
you to take the ticket St from tonight's
show and I want you to put it right
there in the middle of the money huh now
drop
it that the smartest thing to do no it's
like oh to say he robbed his own bank
right like yeah on the side of your
helmet you should feel a button
activates an air duct that connects
Paris to to Las Vegas okay good now you
can press
[Music]
it
what oh wait a second is it all going to
Vegas and they're going to open that
thing money just going to start falling
out uhoh I'm
[Music]
out
what what that's insane that's great but
they're just all allowed to take money
that they know was part of a
robbery I mean it's a cool trick don't
get me wrong but they visually saw a
robbery I would take it I'd be like The
Magicians did it it was still a cool
trick don't again do not mistake it
thank you everyone we are the four Hors
and good night good night but that not
again visual of a crime even if it was
in another country that's crazy that's
nuts is that is that Mark Ruffalo yes it
is we got a lot of comic book actors in
this movie did you just say magicians
yeah D magicians where are you now I'm
in Arya I'm heading up there to grab him
now another comic book actor he's in Man
of Steel I can see him let's go get him
up come on minut do one of you guys mind
giving us a h with our
bags okay so this is like one big long
setup they plan this they want to go to
jail yeah I mean yeah you you don't just
show off a robbery like that unless
you're play I mean I assume they had
like I don't know that they were going
to be like I'm a month two tops away for
blowing this whole thing open another
comic book actor I don't know have time
for this magic crap this crap just
pulled 3 million e out of a Parisian
bank that's how much they got actually
32 alre from inel it's bad enough they
got me chasing down David
Copperfield he believes the magic was
real oh he believes the magic was real
you're right he probably us useless is
it okay with interpole if we talk to him
too thank
you can you explain to me how you went
from Las Vegas to Paris in 3 seconds
with reputation
helmet he was hypnotized during the show
I'll deal with you when I'm done with
this other
[__] oh what come on down you're not
philarmonic how do you say stop in
French
stop you just have to let him finish his
movement okay I need a time out I didn't
know like hypnotism could last like a
long long time yeah we can work together
or you can continue to follow the be and
asking the same exact questions I'm
asking it's up to you come on man
Teamwork Makes the Dream work also she's
very pretty you are a a mentalist tricks
mostly um some science uh targeted
guessing might be a most app description
along with some intuition and the
occasional voices in my head I'm going
to look that up in the dictionary after
we're done if you didn't rob that bank
then you knew about it which makes you
an accomplice so if you want to walk out
of here today you think there's a DA in
the state of Nevada who' be willing to
make sense of this to a jury then we
have a show to perform and you agent
roads have a drawing board to get back
to they do make a cute couple not going
lie literally begging to be arrested you
know that if it means you would actually
do it then yeah but you won't because if
you did it means that you will actually
believe at an Institutional level in
Magic and we'd be even more famous than
we already are and you guys would look
like idiots even more than you already
are don't draw him in and then dump him
because abandon is a big area for him
mommy
daddy I feel like he's about to snap on
him maybe that's his plan because then
he gets to touch him right then he could
then he could do a a trick on him thing
yeah hypnotizing we will always be one
step three steps seven steps ahead of
you and just when you think you're
catching up that's will be right behind
you and at no time will you be anywhere
other than exactly where I want you to
be so come close the closer you think
you are the less you'll actually see I'm
going to nail you oh
holy wrong with that soda M
[Music]
tamale whoa oh my goodness first rule of
magic always be the smartest guy in the
room that was amazing that's
awesome
H I love all of
it it's going to say like what do you
charged that doing magic 3,000 M or
however many miles away they were right
like how do you even how do you prove
that in court I ran a check on the
audience but guess who was sitting there
in the back filming the whole damn thing
I don't know fadus Bradley the guy from
TV with the DVDs in the shows no is that
Morgan Freeman he debunks magicians he
exposes him he shows you how they do the
trip oh okay so yeah it is him L strike
Midland magician my first show I
revealed all of his tricks a year later
he tried to the stage of combat had
himself locked in a safe and dropped to
the
bottom of the East
River the safe was never recovered he
attempted something he was Ill prepared
to handle we were about to do the same
thing but I assure you Vegas was just a
start watch Michael Kane is going to be
a li just I'm just kidding we're trying
to nail the same guy so why don't you
give us a hand now why would I do that
how about I just drag you in right now
on obstruction charges and force you to
tell me unless what you're actually read
really trying to say is is you don't
have any idea how they did it he has
every idea how they did it the real
trick is happening somewhere else I want
to know how they robbed a bank you're an
idiot if you think they robbed a bank
yeah with the eyes see and the ears here
the Mind believes yeah misdirection at
least that's what swordfish told me step
right
up there you go what she's going to turn
to the Hulk how do he get access I was
about to just ask ask how does he and
how let know how to like they're like
we're
nitpickers oh it's just like below the
stage and it looks like uh that's great
so they made a replica personally
preferred to take the stairs so they
picked they picked that guy from the
stage way beforehand yeah got it that's
awesome okay that makes more sense they
chose him they knew which seat he was in
no no no the audience picked the seat he
let them think they picked the seat
actually they were just pming the ball
with the seat number they wanted oh yeah
okay could you just confirm that this is
in fact your seat he was selected yeah
but then they did the hypnotizing trick
too right they programmed his mind to
make him go to Las Vegas and then they
kept reinforcing it until he did oh
nothing was left to chance that's
awesome I got his measurements wow H and
they simply activated him in
yep but how did they know what bank was
his you're kidding really can you be any
more of a condescending ass
yes credit card and that's how they got
the signature for the card you said they
didn't steal the money no I didn't say
they didn't steal the money I said they
didn't run the bank yeah my guess is
that they targeted a shipment of fresh
limited money headed to the Frenchman's
Bank on board an armored truck okay just
as hard to break into unless you're
already
inside M oh God I really thought that
was the greatest magic trick of all time
yeah for our
Horsemen it's almost too
easy nice okay how do they make the
phony money disappear from The
Vault flash
paper magicians use it all the time
huh grief no smoke
leave nor to do I'm actually really
starting to believe my Michael cocaine
is Lyall guy cuz he's getting revenge on
Morgan Freeman I don't know I might be
right on that so what's under it for
truster besides the money ego okay pick
your card look at it put it in the deck
and tmy no don't don't going to say just
take away the trick yeah these guys are
a bunch of Street magicians a year ago
with no resources so how do they go from
doing that to this without some kind of
outside help is this so no my car's
sitting over there that guy's lap she
kind of got it right what I hate is
people who exploit other people by
taking advantage of their weaknesses
they need to believe in something that's
unexplainable is this your card yeah is
this a foreshadowing for something she's
going to do later on the film meaning
like she might be in on it at the or
like do me oh yeah you had a dog a real
tough dog a brutish breed like a real I
want to say Ben the Bulldog I had a
fluffy white cat called
snaffled it's a good name for a cat you
had an uncle on your mother's side some
kind of Paul Thomson was it a Paul
nearly though was I yeah my uncle's name
was kushman
Armitage he should have went through the
alphabet you got an uncle then he needs
to do the a b c d e and watch for eye
movement I already know how to do it and
I've only seen this movie for 20 minutes
he has every member of his crew wearing
a tracking bracel
as long as Alice is tracking them our
boys can track Alice from right here in
the mobile command unit interesting I'd
be like yo am I at work or in prison
what's up with his ankle bracelet well
remember at the first show no one was
allowed to have cell phones there yeah
it's like very controlled environment
totally do I really think it's possible
there's a fifth Horseman yeah fifth
Horsemen is that what you just said oh
yeah huh there is a legend of a secret
Aura born in ancient Egypt called the
eye
it is said they perfected slight of hand
to steal food he's got such an epic
voice I know it's the best him and James
Earl Jones yes using magic and illusion
to even the scales of Justice are the
horsemen next in a long line of fools to
believe this myth H according to your
potential backers you stand to make 2
and A2 million tops from your best
special damn 3 and a half million ah
you're in this to ride them up I'm in a
ride them down I take it that we do not
have a
deal I would take that
deal this isn't the first time I've been
threatened it is however the first time
you've been threatened by
me one who uses a doll to enact one's
own wrath is likely to bring that very
wrath unto himself yeah and I thought
you didn't believe in magic I don't like
it when Alfred and Lucius don't get
along it does make sense though that
like when someone who is so rich like
even if they're in the wrong they can
just pile on pile on people and like
lawyers in court cases I mean it's so
unfair I know it's like it's so
frustrating which is why money gives you
so much power power yeah I always love
that line with Bruce Wayne where they
said what's your superpower I'm rich
Jack Wilder Henley Reeds Meritt mckin
and Daniel Atlas The Four Horsemen all
right whose Bank are they going to rob
Bo this time look as closely as possible
because the tricks you are about to see
may not seem connected but we assure you
they are and now for one of the oldest
tricks in the book oh the rabbit little
bunny fle down down sleep sleep we are
going to debunk a few magic myths this
evening we all know that fluffy is in
fact alive and well a as has the mirror
which makes the Box only appear as
though it's your job is to tackle
dismantle the quarterback who's the
quarterback waa that's
cool perfectly synced man yeah what is
it when you say uh you owe me a coke
Jinx personal Jinx 1 2 35 ttimes 10 he
will be the one saying that word
freeze whoa cool oh that's like a set oh
what if the quarterback is like more
against Freeman or they're trying to
like no that's dope I want to do that
that does look fun I want to go fly in a
bubble yeah I would just suck if you're
like about 15 30 ft high in the bubble
burst like
that some it's like a hero an insulting
hero my favorite kind yeah we ask you to
write down your current bank balance
teal it in an envelope velope now it's
time to take those envelopes out shout
out your name all at once
go why are these people doing this I'd
be like um none of your business count
from 1 to 10 out loud 1 2 3 4 5 is your
bank balance
$562 yeah why are you at a magic show
then yeah I mean you have every right to
you in Vegas period New Orleans oh shoot
right I mean she has every right to
still be there but probably be making
some more money though she's living her
life yeah no no no of course hey go to
do whatever you want of course I'm just
I'm just saying she she's living on the
edge man yeah that's all that's all I
was alluding to for sure this evening
would not be possible if it weren't for
our great benefactor Arthur
Tres see are they going to tackle him
those people and they're going to be
like he's the quarterback and he stole
all their money I took a guess north of
140 am I right that's 140 million oh my
God how can he be right about his
balance and everyone else be wrong I
think possibly because he too is wrong
he's the quarterback like you said using
the flashlight under your seat start to
warm up that paper I think your correct
balance begins to appear oh did they all
just get money we have a flashlight for
you yes oh my God his is now zero what
is going on now weird a second ago it
said
144,50
79,513 70,000
less oh ah what is your new number oh
guess she can be
there6 she can she can be there every
Friday baby heck yeah I mean she's still
got more work to do everyone in this
room was a victim of the hard times that
hit one of America's most treasured
cities but all of you were insured by
the same company
Insurance oh wolf got $882,000 on my
bank account it it says it right here on
my cell phone everybody some cell phones
right now everybody damn I wish I could
have went to a magic show like this did
you do this we'd need access to
information we could never get our hands
on ah yes security questions for
instance like I don't know your mother's
made a name or or the name of your first
pet Snuffles you certainly would never
tell us uh oh
oh my goodness
[Music]
wow oh God this girl's like I'm out of
here he's got no money he's old I ain't
with him
[Applause]
anymore oh cuz he said free cuz he said
freeze the word was freeze
no genius love that I was so off on them
tackling my cocaine oh my God makes
sense why they would choose freeze cuz
they knew he would he would come after
them the way that girl just like
starfish jumped on top of the pile if
anyone's at home and you want to stop
rewind and rewatch that it's
hilarious that was
great I want everyone on the street
everyone do you think they took every
single Dollar in his bank account or
left him I mean they said they left him
with the rose and the and the jet I
don't know right which is why I'm like I
feel like he had I mean he does seem
like he's freaking out but I'm like is
he also part of it like Michael Kane
like he knows like I don't know do you
think he's the fifth Horseman I'd have
no idea I'm like it's maybe but it's all
misdirect I don't yeah like or it could
even be his part I don't know we'll find
out soon
enough uh yeah good luck oh oh is that
one of the tracking things yeah I think
so yeah he's never going to he's never
finding them that's just not happening
am I wrong but is this Marty gr or am I
totally wrong it looks like Marty yeah
with the beads and the colors and the
celebration or maybe it's just a regular
Saturday night in New
Orleans you they like to
[Music]
party what are you doing see like why
did she hesitate yeah like I'm like is
she the fifth Horsemen and that's why
she was doing the cards on the plane
like is there but then I'm like nah why
what would this be like well they also
did say this is her first time on the
field from a desk why is she is she
there as the you know the distraction
pretty French girl shows up out of the
blue acts like she's my partner and then
she lets the bad guy go who exactly are
you
anyway oh yeah see that's where I'm like
she doesn't seem like a magician if she
knows how to like jump over a fence like
that and all this other juice what is
this isn't there something about the eye
at the beginning remember yes like she's
been studying it still don't know about
her I'm back and forth on it Mr Bradley
Mr Trestle would like you to join him
for a drink this makes me when I have a
drink in a hotel it's always a different
vibe it's like is that $3 million check
still good this is a magic trick you sir
are the the distraction while they set
up the trick $140 million distraction
that's quite a distraction yeah whatever
you stand to make I'll double it you
expose them now and Destroy them you
broke bro million have he had 155 mil
and they took 140 so I guess I would
leave him 15 unless I counted wrong yeah
you're right but was it Michael Kane who
the person in the hood is that person
working for Michael Kane or is that
someone totally different cuz I'm I'm a
little lost there remember the person
that was scouting them at the beginning
that's why I was like he's on the plane
right so that's cuz then they started
working for they went to that apartment
that I made a joke about is the Oracle
and that's the I feel like that they
were working for him and then that's how
they got all his well I don't know all
of his well it's going to be revealed at
some point soon who's who they're
working with boy I sure hope so cuz
we're really jumping through hoops right
now yeah we're like so lost I'm sorry
sorry for your arm it was a drunk jerk
I'm sorry I was a drunken [__] yes I
called it candidates for initiations
must follow a series of commands with
blind obedience the horsemen all of this
is only to to join the eye oh that
apartment of the Oracle that's to join
that organization of whatever I think
right have you ever felt something that
you can't see but you know it's there
got a little romantic tension what
you're feeling right now between you and
I whoa what someone has heard every call
read every text that's how they were
able to stay ahead of us God damn and
they also stopped you from having uh
kissed too yeah play
through H stop zoom in tighter tighter
there that's where he took my
phone put it back in and turn on the
phone they don't know that we know about
the bug as of this instant we are ahead
of them that's a good point yeah
oh the firewalls down do they know about
this they who they them whoever we're
working for who are we working for
that's what we want to know yeah we'd
love to know as well watch it's going to
be Morgan Freeman I'm just kidding
probably is Morgan Freeman I just I
don't know like so but this is good I
like that it's not predictable I like
being surprised I'm just literally
throwing names out in the wind right now
seeing which one sticks
FBI
all right they just escaped where okay
we're curious what would they
technically still charge them on I mean
from stealing from him I guess right
yeah exceedingly well how do you like
your horse shredded did they leave them
a little magical surprise in
there oh just this
guy
is that their next Target this looks
like all a setup right cuz they were
like they're here as though they planned
for obviously for them I feel like
they're always 10 steps ahead of yeah of
ah
oh sneaky
[Music]
business what
is okay all
right what no no no
no
no oh my God where are these people
learn to fight you're just supposed to
know
magic come
here I didn't even see what just
happened oh my goodness what game you
playing what game you playing we're all
good at 6 move to seven wait what
interesting how's he doing that he's
like a chameleon he can just he needs to
hear a couple things he can be oh my God
he got it I love him but I'm not that
good yeah flash paper him
out wa dude he's amazing what the heck
it's an Escape Artist this is awesome
waa that's amazing holy to Molly how do
you fight against someone like this you
don't I'd be like I give up hold on hold
on hold
on
really yeah we're doing magic oh ow oh
yeah
nope dang oh no I hate
it ooh I'm s I'm just not jumping in I'm
not yeah here we go
baby give me that
ooh right on top of a nice dirty
mattress that's always fun I'd rather
fall on top of a dirty mattress than
solid Crow though
that's his every Sunday night who told
you fall on top of dirty mattresses
Sunday Mark ruffo's characters had a bad
couple days yeah also who knew that
these magicians also know how to like
fight are they like they're also no Kung
Fu and stuff or whatever it is have
plans for
everything DN she got up quickly to him
oh I was going to say New York traffic
this is uh yeah forget about it kid
there he
is
damn
okay stay with them going to say after
his magician career is over you should
think about being a NASCAR driver or
just a kung fu fighter that too get
over I hate side seat
drivers he is not going to be in the car
I'm telling you he he's gone how we
don't know oh no he's there he's dead oh
wow oh God you guys better get out of
there it's going to
blow yeah oh whoa oh boy that was not
expecting that that really thought he
was not going to be in the car he's dead
I can't even imagine the awful traffic
that would cause yeah is he really dead
though a magician just saying yeah don't
you find it peculiar that inapo will
send you a first timer off the desk to
be your assistant there's a sign in the
case choosing a random card in the deck
he's getting in his head I feel like I'm
playing with somebody wearing ankle
weights keep up agent Rose I almost feel
like he's in with the mag see cuz that's
why I what is going on it's either like
her or now I feel like it's like Morgan
is the fifth one yeah I think Morgan is
the I think he's the one who sent them
the cards and he's testing them he's
yeah to see are they worthy I think it's
I think it's Morgan he's the fifth
Horseman I'm going with that this is the
part you're going to find particularly
interesting agent roads they passed to
my server after they accessed your
mobile
command that's got to hurt I'm taking
over [__] it's got a interesting voice
if we hope to capture the horsemen then
you need to have a little faith in me
cuz I've done nothing to all the wife I
just got my ass handed to me I think
it's too I think it's too obvious for it
to be her yeah now I feel like Morgan
like set her yeah right like is setting
her up yeah he's definitely I think he's
the one who sent the cards that's like
it's got to be I don't know who else it
could be there's like is it just the
mysterious person video taking video of
it all is him
learning where they will eventually lead
to right they're
what is this where the hell is the
goddamn safe sir you got a phone call
and said Washington wants the safe mod
you never heard that come out of my
mouth agent oh the chameleon guy they
get the voices [__]
no what oh god oh he was hypnotized oh
this movie is insane team's loading the
truck oh that's great wow they're so
good wow what the hell's going on new
orders open it
up so we stay with it wherever the safe
goes we go it'll lead us right to him
misdirection yeah but will it though now
they have to know that like the safe is
yeah all
right also yeah way to make it not
obvious by like with all the cop cars
following like what are we doing here
this is not discreet seriously remember
the name Jack Wilder when you see us
live Five Points Queen 7:00 there shows
in a half an hour it's exactly where
we're headed I don't want to be the
nayir but these guys are kind of tricky
yeah God he's finally G he's finally
gaining respect for them saying that you
know he understands with these guys
they're not what they seem right meaning
like there's a reason they want all
these people to go there which is alas
another big distraction I presume we've
got movement someone's walking towards
the truck is it
interpool no oh okay I'm following them
just like you are guess what I'm ahead
of you now if you want to look like even
bigger idiots why not open it the
hell what give me
that oh boy that's awesome I love it get
back one big fat
joke Ah that's great that's what you
guys were
guarding they have you chasing empty
safes again w
once again this Direction that's what we
said yeah we've been saying it the whole
time man don't listen to us
wow oh this is the Lego thing remember
how there was a Lego at the apartment
yeah
yeah that is such a that's the scope of
that crowd that sick W that so cool that
looks awesome how do they do what do you
imagine if you were on asset watching
this I'd be in a hole crying oh my God
it is about belief Faith trust but what
happens if these qualities are not used
for their higher purpose it's gr you're
going to help us set a few things right
H wow they're going in the wrong
direction and you know it the got I got
you
back always going the wrong way wrong
direction yeah never learn even if there
is no I if we were completely played and
we spend the next 20 years in jail then
I just want to say that I know me
too too sentimental for me they're too
cool to go to jail yeah man just saying
they're too entertaining to go to jail
also they know how to break break
through it all they get keys through
soda pops I mean these guys we just we
don't
[Music]
know oh oh that's awesome that's great
did you guys really think it'd be that
easy yeah it's just like yes we are
going to reveal exactly where we'll be
standing come and get
us are they on the other roof okay thank
you for being such an incredible and
dedicated audience so we wouldd like to
start our show tonight by saying goodbye
now you see
me oh who okay for us to
disappear what the are
they whoa no those are projected
people
whoa oh my goodness yes that's awesome
is that Mike cocaine's money oh no he
gave that away already too
[Music]
late godam like dude why are you
crumpling that put in your pocket yeah
I'd be taking it all so I guess this is
it is
it oh wow okay she went in for the kill
he's like oh wow I should lose all my
cases and insult my partners I can see
why she was into him I mean he insulted
her whenever he could he questioned her
I mean what what would you not want
oh where's the real money is this our
fifth Horseman is it in the back of this
oh my goodness oh they set up Morgan
Freeman oh nice that's what you get for
trying to expose us yes for trying to
expose magicians and so Ah that's great
that's great so it was all just like a
ploy to like get money also reel him in
knowing that he would be following them
but also why else I still want to know
who was in charge of the oh was that
Lyall guy that went into the safe but
maybe it it wasn't Michael cocaine but
who is that ly guy cuz at the beginning
remember Morgan Freeman said that ly guy
he exposed him he is he's still alive my
opinion I just want to know who he is
I'm been framed I'm sure you are yeah
but I can prove it remember the rapid
trick in the second
show the box was never empty the room
wasn't either what oh transformed the
whole room into a giant rabbit box you
drop your guard and leave oh with the
mirror
oh damn that's brilliant wow brilliant
is that is that did he survive is that
what's his name it looks like him Dave
Franco's
character oh my God that is so much
money yep he survived how did he survive
that accident it's locked weren't you
listening nothing's ever
locked well done Mr Wilder he's the
greatest escape artist ever he escaped
in a standard FBI vehicle right
yeah you to the bridge where the other
horsemen were waiting with an identical
replacement oh I only took a split
second for you to lose contact with it
make the
switch wait oh wait how
what oh my God and then that is uh uhhuh
okay damn that is amazing that's awesome
wow that is quite the plan to really
looking to Lono shrike the insurer who
denied fam's claim trest their insurance
the bank that carried the note credit
Republican of Paris okay now it's
playing no it's not what if all this was
just leading up to us getting mugged in
Central Park at 2: a.m. no I'm telling
you we're right where we need to be oh
remember that thing she said about the
tree growing in the park for 20 years
something like that the Lionel shrike
tree and the card encased in glass
that's
right
whoa that is so cool what I see you
that's
awesome open
SES oh
the Is It Michael K I don't know that
was my prediction early on but I don't
know and the FBI got past them not once
not twice consistently almost as if they
were on the in
inside
oh God it was Mark no are you kidding
me
you what holy junk oh my God I did not
see that coming at all I want you to
spend the rest of your life in this cell
how you let yourself be so blinded by
your ego that you convinced yourself
that you were one step ahead when you
were always two steps behind oh my God
oh my goodness I did not see that coming
me me neither that was a really good
twist I'm not going to lie yeah like I
mean it was it was a really convincing
Chase I did not see that coming I me too
he's speaking when I said always be the
smartest guy in the room we were in
agreement I was testing you I have
always been a 100% believer in the
amount of energy I have expended to keep
these infidels on
point this is awesome this is a great
twist Welcome to the
what what's going to happen what oh what
what it's a great twist but so he had to
be an FBI agent for all those years
saying like how exactly for him that was
my main thing of like yeah but he's part
of the FBI where people know him and
trust him he's on a team that takes a
lot of time effort
yeah it was all connected credit
Republican Trust insurance and elorn
what's the connection to Shri is that
Elias cus elorn started as a safe
manufacturer they used cheap steel and
when he got to the bottom of the river
the safe warped and he was trapped he
was your father oh was his dad oh that's
why he hates Morgan Freeman yep exposed
his dad The Logical conclusion for you
to take this case to its resolution and
for you to turn me in she like yeah that
sounds right
that I think some things are best left
unexplained one more secret to lock
away a that's cute so is he going to
still continue to be an FBI agent I mean
I I think yeah I guess you still got to
keep it up right
yeah we are bonded forever with this
lock on the count of three open your
eyes and tell me what you see 1 2
okay oh oh it was Lis leer who directed
this this was the director of Incredible
Hulk it's funny that he oh yeah and
that's why well no um Mark Mark he
wasn't the one but but but fun fact even
though Ed Norton was the Hulk in that
film he actually wanted Mark Ruffalo to
be the Hulk before yeah but they
actually got Edward Norton and then
there was maor clash between Kevin feige
Marvel and Ed Norton so like yeah let's
go with Mark
Ruffo cool that he finally got to work
with Mark Ruffo so um I'm always a
sucker for a great twist and again the
whole I I do have some questions about I
mean I'd have to really think about it
more in terms of again you know revenge
is a is a Fickle matter and you know
what Morgan Freeman did to Mark
ruffalo's father I can understand
wanting to hey I'm GNA have to come up
with some elaborate ploton scheme and
I'm going to have to join the FBI and
then I'm going to have to search out
magician and skap part and blah blah
blah so I guess I could buy into this
again if I really thought way too hard
on him I'd probably come up with some
logic of yeah this plan's not going to
work but I could probably do that with a
lot of movies that I love and just you
know what it was a great twist but again
in the comment section if you think I'm
wrong and say hey Andrew you're wrong it
was a crap twist that's cool um but I I
liked it um I did not see it coming yeah
I didn't at all again I was under the
impression it was probably Michael Kane
was it was him or or the woman or maybe
it was morganan so again I really didn't
see it as Mark Ruff so I'm again I'm a
sucker for a good twist and I also just
I'm also a sucker for magic in general
and I just loved all the uh just the uh
just all the magician stuff all the
magic stuff it was just it was really it
was elaborate it was fun I just I I just
loved it oh it was great uh this was it
was a fun ride this movie what you think
it was a lot of fun I feel like him
being 12 though and carrying that Grudge
throughout his entire life is like wow
that's tough I get that you would also
need many many years to think this
through but I also think like God life
you get through like high school and
college and people come your way and
you're probably like uh how am I still
going to get I'm just Mark ruffo's
character in this I'm like you have a
lot of resolve buddy the fact from 12
until now and you carried it through
cool um the one scene that keeps like in
my head keeps messing me up is that when
Morgan calls him and tells him that girl
was not a signed to you she chose it
right why why is she throwing off your
game that he so genuinely was like wait
she was she was assigned like she had to
be on this case right why would that
that that's the only thing that I'm like
oh of course it would mess him up maybe
that one little detail but he really
worked he worked out the whole thing
like he saw the whole plan ahead of him
so uh the phone call thing was the main
thing that threw me off from that I
think because he was so genuine about
like wait what do you mean this girl she
could not and then he yells at her being
like I'm not asking you I'm asking him
um when I'm like yeah but the whole time
he was in on the entire thing right and
he didn't need to be mad in front of
anyone else to make the thing work right
so um you know I'd be interested too in
a rewatch just like now that we know the
twist like looking at all the signs of
Mark Ruffalo because when you watch this
in in the first it really just before I
accidentally spoil it cuz I don't want
to have you seen the film The Fugitive
with Tommy Lee Jones and Harrison Ford
yeah okay well I'm not going to spoil
anyways in that film Tommy Le Tommy Lee
Jones is on the hunt for Harrison Ford
that's all I'm going to say about that
but it really felt like you know that in
a sense of Mark Ruffalo is really going
hunting them down and will do anything
to stop them and from that perspective I
loved it and like I would have never
ever that's why I never would have
guessed the twist in this in terms of
like that no he's the one who hired them
in the beginning right and he's putting
in all that effort yeah which was great
and then also too like he's ridiculing
the interpole woman and he's and he's
like actually physically fighting them
and doing I'm like this is what messes
me up yeah know that's great for a first
time watch it throws us off the SC but
also I'm like yeah but we're are you
also an actor as your character right
because he doesn't it's yeah that's that
all of that is like oh even when you're
sitting down to write the script you're
like it may not make total sense
yell to his work he does but um it makes
it better obviously for the story for
the audience I have no doubt there were
a rare group of people that might have
guessed that it might have
been yeah Mark Ruffalo and off to you
people but I got to imagine it was a
rare rare few but still that's um again
I I really did enjoy it but again my
favorite part of this film besides that
twist was watching the camaraderie and
The Chemistry Between the four of them I
thought they all did such a great job
and I loved all their interactions and
the way they worked with each other and
the way they got comfortable with each
other too like even when he's like just
the simple interaction when they were in
the elevator he's like you know in all
the in the year we worked together I
just want to say uh I thought you were a
dick and uh yeah that's it I just little
interactions like that just I get
invested in car in character
interactions like that and again I just
thought they all had such great
chemistry and I loved watching them
again work together and I also love
scenes to when they were like wait how
did they do that thing with the safe and
I I like that instead of talking about
it they showed us how they came up with
these schemes and I thought it was just
fun the way they do it in a nonlinear
way oh yeah how they tied like the the
mirror thing with the rabbit to the to
the case thing in the big like thing
you're like oh my God okay and again
it's also for like when you come to
rewatch for a second third or fourth
time like for shading okay this is cool
except you don't know to look for that
big of a foreshadow in one little
instance of of a trick right totally but
I think that's why we thought the or at
least why I thought the foreshadowing
was her playing with cards on the plane
with Mark ruffo's character being like
is she trying to throw him off some
scent and make herself look like I'm
learning but like she knows everything
like that that also was a thing where I
was like any little thing in here is it
foreshadowing which is probably their
their ploy to be like yeah you're going
to think it's everything else except for
the one thing that you're staring at the
entire time during this movie I don't
know if it would warrant an actual I
mean I know they made a sequel which I
don't know anything about um if this is
obviously uh gets a good number of views
obviously I assume we're going to do a
reaction but um point I'm making is I
even I was very fascinated and um
obviously I as mentioned many times I
love that twist with Mark Ruffalo I'd be
very fascinated even if they showed a
flashback I don't need like per se a
whole movie of just with Morgan
Freeman's character and Mark ruffo's
father Elias CZ in terms of what what
right how did we get here yeah like I
mean I just I was actually very and
again I was most fascinated about just
what was going on with our four main
characters and Mark Ruffalo the Chase
and all that stuff cuz just it was so
mesmerizing all that all that fun stuff
and all the magic just throw magic I'm
entertained um but uh I mean yeah if you
give me even um I I don't know if it's
going to be necessary now you see me too
because I don't have no idea what the
plot is in that film but I even if it
was in this film which again was not
necessary but I would would have
definitely been intrigued if even it was
like a 5 10 minute scene where if they
would have just just Vis us a little
more foundation between Morgan and the
dad just just so I could have had just a
little bit of a visual again even with
the dialogue that they gave me that was
definitely enough this is not a
criticism it's just something like I
would have loved to have seen yeah well
it gives us that payoff more right
because you're saying if you saw that
Foundation set up feel Mark feel his
revenge more I still felt it but I would
have felt it even more I kind of did but
not really until the end and I went and
we went oh now we see the connection
which yes you would you would want to
like kill those people or mess them up
right Morgan's character bad enough I I
would be like I mean again I still was
on Mark ruffo's side in terms of I get
where he's coming from and I would
totally like if I that were me in his
position I would totally want Morgan
Freeman in there for the rest of his
natural life but if you show it to me
it's like I'm so on board with you I'm
get him in that jail Cale like show me
the dad dying in the in the safe in the
ocean and then the kid there and he's
lonely and he's now without a dad like
it show us a little bit I mean that's
the beginning of every Disney movie
right parent dies kids left alone we're
all like Weeping at the end because of
the foundation they've set up out of
subject question I'm very curious so
Elias CZ who of course played the great
Casey Jones and Turtles teen Ninja
Turtles one and three he plays Mark ruff
father as we see in the newspaper
clipping there uhhuh how much does he
get paid just for a newspaper clipping
of his photo like I'm just curious how
much do you get paid for I I guess if
your face is in there I mean you're not
going to get you're not getting nothing
you're getting something for that
something I don't know how much that
would be though that'd be uh whatever
they offered I mean if it's more than
it's I mean still whatever you get it's
like here's a picture here's some money
here you go that's awesome either I
wonder that's a good question son of the
gross thank you very much I doubt it it
works for me like he didn't do any work
he's like here's a head shot from 1979
you guys can use that yeah overall
though I I had a blast with this movie
it was a lot of fun um there's a reason
it's 7.2 on IMDb and it has almost like
4.5 Stars this movie is wildly
entertaining it moves really quick it
has good dialogue and it constantly
keeps you guessing which I really enjoy
and there's I mean a lot of these movies
I feel like I'm not I'm we can be
somewhat ahead we're like ah we really
saw that coming without like telling you
guys that and this one I was I was just
guessing I was throwing [__] at the wall
you guys heard and I was not right in
any of that well that's one of my
biggest pet peeves is when I'm able to
predict things and I know sometimes I
get criticized for that in the comments
like stop predicting stop spoiling
things just enjoy it's like that's one
of the things I like doing is predicting
things not he likes to spoil yes I know
sorry guys no I it's it's it's not that
I like it's just sometimes I just and
again it's it's hard writing for sure I
get it I've tried to attempt to do and I
suck at it I I'll admit it uh it's very
difficult to write so um I I just like
playing the prediction game but on this
on the flip side that's one of my pet
peeves I hate being able to predict
things so when something is able to
really get me on a Twist I'm genuinely
happy to when I see it oh yeah and I
mean the thing is
you guys know when you watch so many
movies and so much TV and you golf so
much media you kind of see twists and
turns coming you're just like they're
just following tropes of a thing this
movie just didn't follow any tropes I've
seen before and made it wildely
entertaining with really good actors
that I believe that were like grounded
the my biggest pet peeve which I you
guys have heard me say if I don't
believe the actors then I kind of I'm
like I'm out the illusion it breaks yeah
it's like I can't I can't handle that
and the guys were great super grounded
everyone in it awesome awesome awesome
great casting which I always uh very
much appreciate um yeah I would give it
out of 10 I'm G to go for like an an
eight an eight out of 10 I would maybe
even go like 8.5 thank you we've I was
going to say I'm going for an eight so
we can't have the same score yeah I'll
put it I'll put it up to an 8.5 because
I thought this was just it was a blast
like I would have this is a lot of fun I
would have loved to be having like some
whiskey I would and watch this so that
anytime Mar R's like I'm getting a drink
I'd be like me too if they would have
showed me that flashback scene it would
have been I'm just kid uh no no no but
I'll go with an eight that's still a
high score so yeah maybe it's in the
second one who knows maybe they set the
foundation there okay then if they put
it in the second one I'll go back to an
8.5 for this one but okay well well well
he's moving he seems like a Fickle guy
right he's back and forth on it
depending upon if they set the
foundation or not exactly that's exactly
how I am okay well I mean I think those
are our last thoughts you guys need to
put in the comments number one just be
like hey you're cool tell tell me if you
like my new t-shirt it's big it's
oversized it says Los Angeles with a
cool car on it gives me a Miami Vice
type of feel I like it
like9 maybe it's 80s I don't know I
don't know what anything from 80s or 90s
I was born obviously in 2005 look at my
face um any last words just uh Batman
man I'm Batman uh no just uh this like I
said this was a fun Entertain Me
Entertain Me Entertain entertaining film
uh edge of your seat fun twist or good
twist rather uh fun characters and like
you said really grounded and and Magic
entertaining film I really enjoyed stuff
we had a blaster Ro we love you guys and
we'll see you on the next one
[Music]
bye